The idea of what you're looking for
in those initial employees,
is it's a really important one.
They have to be jacks of all trades and
they have to be passionate but
they also and, in fact, I think this is
just when you're looking for employees
in any whether it's a start up, whether
they're your first employee or hundreds.
What you really want are people that
have a very specific skill, but
are willing, and
this is where the passion comes in,
are willing to do whatever it takes,
whether it's their job,
whether it's their specialty, whether
it's kind of outside their comfort zone.
Because if you think about a start up
the grows is going, the people that
start, their rules are going to change
every six months, significantly.
The first person that
handles marketing for
you could be your VP eng in a year and
a half.
You never know what's
going to happen and
you need the most adaptable
people you can find.
And I think that adaptability,
some of it's a core trait but
a lot of that is really
just willingness and
passion and an ability to learn fast
which is super important obviously.